good morning good afternoon hello
everyone and welcome to today's live
broadcast
sepsis diagnosis role of data analytics
and specimen collection
processing and laboratory efficiency
i'm alexis krauss of labberts and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lapperts and sponsored
by
bed for more information about our
sponsor
please visit their website at bd.com
so let's get started i would like to
remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click on the send
button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr patrick murray vice president of
worldwide microbiology
at bd life sciences for a complete
biography on our presenter
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr murray you may now begin your
presentation
welcome sir thank you alexis
and i want to thank everyone who's
calling in for this program i hope that
it's going to be informative
and that you'll find the information
that i'll present to be useful
for for your work this
is an outline of the material that i'm
going to cover
we have a focus on blood cultures best
practices and the clinical value
of blood cultures and so i'll start with
the role of the microbiology laboratory
in sepsis management
then i'll provide a definition of the
best processes for the collection
transport and processing of blood
cultures
in other words best practices for sepsis
diagnosis
this will lead to challenges for the
laboratory
to optimize the efficiency and the
clinical value of the work they do
and then finally i will end with a
discussion of
data-driven clinical value through the
application of
analytics
when we think about the global health
issues we have to think
of both the human and the financial
burdens associated with
sepsis globally it's been estimated that
almost 15 million cases of sepsis are
diagnosed
were diagnosed in 2017
with approximately 11 million deaths
reported
to put this into perspective
we're in the midst of a pandemic and the
pandemic is just approaching now one
million deaths
so in other words it's more than when we
talk about sepsis
the damage caused by sepsis in terms of
human lives is tenfold greater than what
we see with the covid
pandemic sepsis is the leading cause of
mortality and
critical illnesses worldwide with
hospital mortality rates
approaching 25 to 30 percent
and clinical studies have demonstrated
there is a two-fold
increase in sepsis related mortality
when the wrong antibiotics are given as
part of the antimicrobial therapy
and finally blood cultures remain a
critical tool for the microbiology
laboratory
to support the management of septic
patients
now when we think about the impact of
sepsis management think about
what it would be like without
diagnostics that is
when we rely on empiric therapy versus
having diagnostics to direct the therapy
for these patients and for the next
couple of slides what i want to do is to
illustrate this point
so first of all we have to think about
what diagnostics are
and what i'm speaking of diagnostics
we're talking about blood cultures
we're talking about microbial
identification and we're talking about
antibiotic susceptibility testing
in the absence of diagnostic tests
patients have to be treated
empirically and what's been found is
that patients that are put on
inappropriate empiric antibiotics
increase experience increased mortality
increased length of hospitalization and
that in turn means
increased hospital costs with the
pharmacy or the laboratory
with patient care so let me look at each
of these points and
provide a little bit more data to
support these comments
we'll start off with the impact of
empiric therapy
and i'm going to cite four studies and
these in fact are
four reviews looking at a large number
of studies of sepsis in patients
so as an example the first the first
study by paul
and co-workers looked at 70 studies of
sepsis in adults
and what they found was that in more
than half of these studies
greater than 25 percent of the patients
received empiric therapy that was
inappropriate
raymond and co-workers did the same type
of study but in this case they looked at
septic patients
with gra with infections caused by
gram-negative bacilli
and of the 57 studies that they looked
at
almost three-quarters of those studies
again
saw that greater than 25 of the patients
were treated
inappropriately with empiric therapy
herrera and co-workers reviewed 191
studies
of almost 75 000 patients
and they found that in one-third of the
patients
the empiric therapy was inappropriate
and finally silverberg and co-workers in
a multi-center study of 175 u.s
hospitals
observed that when inappropriate therapy
was administered
the patients with infections caused by
carbon and resistant organisms
the mortality was four-fold greater than
what you saw with
susceptible patients and that's logical
because these patients
have infections with organisms that are
resistant to almost all
antibiotics so you would expect that
you're going to see a higher proportion
of these patients
being treated inappropriately so this
underscores the value of diagnostics for
these patients
because the diagnostic tests are going
to support the detection
and diagnosis of drug resistant
infections
it's going to reduce the use of
inappropriate antibiotics because it's
going to be guiding
the therapy with the antimicrobial
susceptibility test
this results in improved patient
outcomes
and because the patients are in the
hospital for a shorter period of time
because they're doing fewer diagnostic
tests because they have a diagnosis
this is going to decrease the hospital
cost
blood cultures are the key diagnostic
test for substance management
because it's going to identify the
organism responsible for sepsis
it's going to allow us to identify those
organisms and perform antimicrobial
susceptibility tests
but then we can select the most
appropriate antibiotic
for the treatment of these patients but
for this to be valuable
the blood culture results have to be
rapid and to have to be accurate
so let's talk about each of these issues
for rapid accurate suscep blood
cultures requires the use of best
practices for both the collection of the
blood cultures
and the processing of the blood cultures
what this
means is that we have to disinfect the
skin properly so we reduce
contaminated blood cultures we have to
collect the sufficient volume of blood
to maximize the recovery of the pathogen
that is to maximize the proportion of
collective blood cultures that are going
to be
positive and we have to implement good
workflow practices
in both the transport of the specimen to
the laboratory
as well as processing that specimen in
the laboratory
so again let's look at these issues
we'll start off with contaminated blood
cultures
what's been found with a contaminated
blood culture is that these are
associated with a significant
increase in hospital costs there's an
increase in the pharmacy cost
because antibiotics are being
administered unnecessarily
and there's an increase in the
laboratory cost
because you have to verify that in fact
that
isolate which turns out to be a
contaminant was truly in that patient's
blood
and not a contaminant because of the
additional testing that's required and
because of the treatment
the patients are also going to
experience an increased length of stay
so when we think about blood cultures
that are contaminated this is not a
trivial problem
this in fact is quite expensive for the
hospital
and for the laboratory it's really
wasted efforts
trying to identify this organism and
process additional
blood cultures now we can decrease
contamination by a variety of different
techniques
and i will say that the most effective
techniques are the ones that actually
use
combinations of what i've described here
you want to standardize the collection
protocols
and provide collection kits in order to
provide that standardization
ideally for blood coaches you want to
have dedicated phlebotomy teams
that understand the value of the blood
culture understand the proper techniques
for disinfecting the skin
and understand how to collect the proper
volume of blood
for each blood culture that's processed
we can also reduce contamination through
education and training programs
um the challenge there of course is that
in order for these to be sustained we
have to repeat this type of education
and training on a regular basis
we can also reduce contamination by
monitoring
the contaminated blood cultures to
identify
areas in the hospital where we see this
frequently such as in the emergency
department
or in an icu and then provide feedback
so that the phlebotomist in those areas
can improve their technique and reduce
the contaminated blood cultures
finally we can also what's called blood
diversion
techniques we can also use these
techniques to reduce the contamination
if you think about it when the skin is
disinfected
and the needle is inserted into a vein
to collect the blood
the first portion of the blood has the
greatest likelihood of being
contaminated
if the skin wasn't properly disinfected
so what has been found is that if that
first portion of blood
that can be one ml or less is discarded
or used for another diagnostic test
then what we find is that the percent of
positive blood
of contaminated blood cultures will be
decreased
the goal for the measurement that we
should use
for demonstrating that
blood cultures are collected in the
proper fashion and reducing
contamination is that the contamination
rate should be less than two percent of
all blood cultures that are collected
so that's a guideline that we can use
but certainly if all the techniques that
i've mentioned here are implemented
we'll actually see that that
contamination rate will be less than one
percent
now the success of obtaining a positive
blood culture and ultimately that's our
goal
we want to have a positive blood culture
it's going to be determined by one
variable one very important variable and
that is the amount of blood that's
cultured
the reason for this and i've highlighted
in three boxes here the reason for this
is that most septic patients
have less than one organism circulating
per ml
of blood so there's very few organisms
in the bloodstream
and you can imagine if the patient has
let's say
pneumonia or a urinary tract infection
for the organisms to enter the blood
it's really a spillage of
excess organisms at the site of
infection
and so these organisms that are spilled
into the blood
then are diluted by all of the blood in
patients body
and you also have phagocytic cells that
are removing these organisms
so it's no wonder that we see very few
organisms in the patient's bloodstream
on average most blood culture bottles
are filled with less than 25 percent of
the recommended 10 mls of blood
for an adult patient and again i'm going
to show some data
to support these statements as i go
through here
but what we see is on average the
bottles are grossly under
filled and then finally the last point
is that there are numerous clinical
studies that have demonstrated
if the blood culture bottles are filled
properly
the proportion of positive blood
cultures will
increase by 40 to 50 percent
so let's look at some of the data now
that supports each of these statements
we'll start off with quantitation now
the quantitative studies that have been
performed are primarily older studies
where they were doing quantitative blood
cultures
and probably the best system for doing
this was the
isolator where blood was collected into
a
vacuum tube with a lysine agent
the blood cells were lysed the organisms
were concentrated by centrifugation
and then that portion of the blood was
inoculated onto plates
and so you can literally count the
number of colonies and calculate the
number of
colony forming units that were
circulating in the patient's blood
now i've cited five studies here that
look at this type of data
and what you're going to see is that
each has roughly the same conclusion
we'll start off with henry at all at the
mayo clinic
it was published in 1983 and what they
found was that for staph aureus
bacteremias
25 26 of these factoremias
had less than one organism per ml for e
coli and pseudomonas
more than half of those bacteremias had
less than one organism
male of blood and for yeast infections
in this study
what they found was 36 percent had less
than one
organism so virtually all of the
significant organisms gram-positive
gram-negative and yeast had very few
organisms in the bloodstream
surrounding co-workers in 1991 looked at
the same issue with gram-negative rods
and they found that just over half of
the bacteremias
with gram-negative bacteria had less
than one organism per milliliter
valencia and co-workers looked at yeast
and in their study
they found that 70 percent of the
fungemias had less than one organism per
milliliter of blood
in pediatric and in neonates we expect
to see a higher
number of organisms circulated in the
bloodstream
because essentially they have less
volume of blood to dilute the organisms
in
but we also know that for children and
for neonates
we can we have to collect a smaller
volume of blood for culture
so what we found with the study in
children that
the scala presented
was that for haemophilus influenza about
32 percent
of the bacteremias with this organism
had less than 100 colony forming units
per milliliter
and beets men for neonates found the 23
of the patients with e coli bacteremia
had less than five organisms per
milliliter and again remember
with the neonates you may only collect
one to two mls of blood just because of
the size of the child
so as we look at as we look at
all of the bacteremia studies that have
been performed where they did
quantitative studies
what we see is that a significant
proportion of these
bacteremic and fungic patients have very
few
organisms in the bloodstream so let's
take this one step further now
and let's look let's look at the bottles
themselves and how much blood is being
put
into the bottles most blood culture
bottles
require eight to ten milliliters of
blood per bottle to be cultured
and i signed here seven studies that
actually measured the amount of blood
that was being put into the bottles
the first study by harwood in pediatric
bottles they found that less than half
of them
were properly filled abrams
found that one-third of the adult
patients
the blood cultures for them were
properly filled only one-third were
properly filled
in the study that was published in the
european journal of clinical
microbiology and infectious diseases
in the european study they found that 13
of the adult bottles were properly
filled
lynn and co-workers reported in 2013
that less than three percent of the
adult bottles were properly filled
uh couture and reported in 2018
20 of the adult bottles were properly
filled
a very consistent theme that we see here
over and over and over
very few bottles are being properly
filled
chain and kahari did something that was
a little bit different
and i and i think it's important to
understand this because
rather than measure what the portion of
the bottles were
properly filled or improperly filled
what they did
is they looked at how much blood was
actually being put
into the bottles and what they found was
very consistently in both studies
about the same amount of blood on
average
the mean blood volume from an adult
patient
was 2.6 ml in one steady and 2.3 ml
per bottle in another study in other
words
it would appear that about five mls of
blood was being collected
and divided between two bottles in those
studies
so what we see again is that
most blood culture bottles are not being
properly filled
so if we understand that the level of
bacteremia the quantitative
level of bacteremia and fungi is low
and most bottles are under filled what's
the impact of this
and again we have a series of studies
that have been reported
and i've just actually pulled five
studies
to be able to illustrate this point uh
there's other studies in the literature
but very consistently we see the same
thing
depending on the volume of blood you're
going to see it's
a proportion increase in positive blood
cultures
so the timmy study
looked at the difference between
collecting
and culturing 2 mls of blood and 5 mls
of blood
and they found that there was a 7.8
percent
increase of the larger volume of blood
moving from 5 ml to 10 ml
paul looked at this and found there is
the 13.4 percent increase
kim did the same type of study many
years later
and now with what would be considered a
modern blood culture system
and saw exactly the same thing doubling
the volume of blood from 5
ml the 10 mls resulted in almost a 15
percent
increase in positive blood cultures
ill strep in a very large study looked
at increasing from 10 mls to 20 mls 20
mls being the recommended volume
for two bottles and found a 38
increase and then patel
looked at a variety of different volumes
they collected multiple cultures each
culture with each bottle with 10 mls of
blood
and what they found was that when they
went from 10 mls to 20 mls there was a
25
increase 10 mls to 30 mls
there was a 35 percent increase in the
males the 40 ml
there was almost a 50 increase and when
they collected
60 ml of blood or six bottles with 10 ml
in each they had almost a 65
increase so again
this would be what you would expect very
few organisms are circulating in the
blood
what we find is that most bottles are
under filled
and when the bottles are properly filled
we see a significant increase in
positive blood cultures
and ultimately that's what we're trying
to do with the blood culture
what we want to be able to do is
maximize
the number of positive blood cultures we
process
for our patients so to summarize this
relatively few organisms circulate in
the blood of patients with
infections so a large volume of blood
must be cultured for a maximum number of
positive cultures
blood culture bottles are consistently
under filled
so many cultures are potentially false
negative cultures
so to maximize the value the value of
blood cultures
we should collect 10 mls of blood per
bottle
collect two bottles per culture an
aerobic
and an anaerobic bottle and do two
cultures per patient
this will maximize the value of the
blood cultures we try to make diagnosis
of sepsis in a patient i should point
out one thing and that is
i said an aerobic bottle in an anaerobic
bottle
and frequently i hear the comments well
we don't see anaerobic infections so we
don't really need the anaerobic bottle
i will remind everyone in this audience
that the vast majority of organisms that
we
isolate from blood are what we would
call
either strict aerobic organisms
organisms like pseudomonas or
yeast or facultative anaerobic organisms
that has organisms that grow aerobically
and anaerobically and these would
include the staphylococci the
streptococci the enterococci
and most of the gram negatives all of
the enterobacteriaceae
so the value of that anaerobic bottle
is to yes detect strict anaerobes but
more importantly to maximize the amount
of blood that's being collected
for gram negative infections like with
the intro bacteriaceae
and gram-positive infections as with
staphylococci streptococci
and enterococci
now what i'd like to do is talk a little
bit about laboratory workflow
and really when we talk about workflow
it has
it has to extend beyond the laboratory
we have to think about the blood
cultures are ordered
assessments are collected they go to a
nursing station which then sends them to
the laboratory
when the bottles arrive in the
laboratory they have to be accessioned
and then placed into an instrument a
blood culture instrument
and after they've incubated for a
sufficient period of time you get a
signal that the bottles are positive
the bottles then have to be removed and
the identification test the gram stain
the identification
and the antimicrobial susceptibility
tests are performed
i will tell you that each one of these
steps
there's an opportunity for significant
delays
and just to put it in perspective if we
think about how long it takes
for a gram-positive organism to grow in
a blood culture bottle on
average it's a little bit less than 15
hours
if you think about gram negatives they
tend to grow faster
and it's an average of about 10 to 12
hours for them to become positive
so when i talk about the amount of time
from when a specimen is collected
to when results are reported keep in
mind
that it's between 10 and 15 hours that
the majority of the bottles
will become positive in the incubator so
any time beyond that there's
opportunities for delays that we have to
consider
now one area where we see
significant delay is from when the
bottles are collected to when they're
received in the laboratory and put
into the incubator
and what we've found is that where
that's the greatest delays
are where you see the greatest patient
activity so things like in the emergency
department
where there's many patients going
through the emergency department
we see significant delays in getting the
bottles
from collection to incubation another
areas
in intensive care units where again
great deal of patient activity
and despite the fact these patients are
critically ill
we may not see the bottles in the
laboratory in the incubator for a
significant period of time
one approach to reduce that is actually
to put the blood culture
incubators near the patient where the
specimens are being collected and so
this was
one study that looked at the impact of
putting blood culture bottles
in the emergency department and what
they found
was that uh the first call the second
column there where it says dd2
2014 this is the year 2014
in the emergency department when bottles
were being sent to the laboratory
and what they found was from the time it
was sampled to when the incubation
started
was on average 11 hours
the next year what they did is put the
incubator in the emergency department
and what they found was
on average it was one tenth of an hour
or about
what six minutes to get the bottles into
the incubator
and so as you think about this what
we've done here is eliminate
11 hours of transit time
that's significant almost a half a day
and what is the impact of that
rather than go through the amount of
time before
it turned positive or gram stain result
or identification result
what i want to do is look at the amount
of time for the final report that is
when the susceptibility results are
issued
and when the bottles were incubated in
the emergency department
it was i'm sorry when they were sent to
the laboratory
it was on average 58 hours from
collection
to final results from the when the
bottles were incubated in the emergency
department
it removed 11 hours it went to 47 hours
from collection to final report i don't
think that's good
but what it does illustrate is that at
least this approach
has eliminated almost a half a day in
getting the results back to the position
i want to look at the european
experience with how they process
blood cultures because i think this this
is telling that i'm going to look at the
european experience
and then look at the u.s experience
in europe last year there was a study
that was reported
in clinical microbiology and infection
where they surveyed over 200
laboratories in 25 european countries so
very wide distribution
of both laboratories and countries
and they asked questions about blood
collection transport and
incubation and what they found was that
in
42 of the labs the bottles were
i'm sorry 40 42
of the bottles were incubated upon
receipt
24 hours a day seven days a week in
other words
almost 60 percent of the laboratories
did not process blood cultures in a
timely way
for for a significant proportion of
their bottles
if they if you look at processing
positive bottles
only 13 of those bottles were processed
as soon as the bottles became positive
so
more than 85 percent had significant
delays
in taking the bottles out of the
incubator and processing them
only 15 of the laboratories
um i'm sorry 15 did not process
bottles on sunday or in holidays so
a proportion of the of the laboratories
weren't doing blood culture processing
on a sunday or a holiday
the patients still get sick patients are
sick on sundays and on holidays
so seriously we should be looking at how
we can maximize
processing those cultures and then
finally fewer than five percent recorded
the results
24 hours a day seven days a week so even
though they had a positive blood culture
they may have had an identification or
an antimicrobial susceptibility result
it didn't report those in a timely way
and so as we look at
workflow we can see significant
opportunities
for how we can improve workflow this is
the european labs
let's look at the u.s labs and again
this was a study i was involved with
that we reported a couple of years ago
that looked at all blood cultures that
were processed in 13 hospitals
between an 18-month period between
january
2015 to july 2016.
we had more than 165 000 blood cultures
that were
processed in these fifth in these 13
hospitals
and over 15 000 were positive or almost
10 percent of the blood cultures were
positive
so a very large data set in which to
analyze the
uh the workflows of these laboratories
the median time and again remember from
it takes about 10 to 15 hours for a
positive blood culture
uh once it's being incubated the median
time from specimen collection to a
positive
gram stain the first report
was 20.4 hours so anywhere from
a 5 to 10 hour delay that we see here
the median time from specimen collection
to identification
was almost 44 hours or almost
one day later after the gram stain
and this again remember this is the time
when we have a number of rapid
identification techniques
like maldi to in order to be able to get
results in minutes
not days and then finally the median
time from specimen collection to
antimicrobial susceptibility results
was 66 hours or almost one day
after the identification was reported
and two days after the susceptibility
results were reported
so why is there a delay and what we did
is we analyzed this
and we looked at a 24-hour period to see
when results were being reported
now if we start off with specimen
collection
we see specimen collection throughout
the day
evening and night i broke this into six
hour
increments so the first bar there
represents
specimens that were collected between
midnight and six in the morning
the second bar from six in the morning
until noon
the third bar from noon until six in the
evening
and then the last bar from six in the
evening until midnight
and yes you see the majority or you see
a significant proportion of blood
cultures collected
during what we'd say be the working
hours
but they are collected throughout the
day and evening
now you would expect if there's no
delays that are introduced
what you're going to find is that the
this graph will just shift into
different time
frames but the distribution would look
very similar
in fact that's not the case if we look
at gram stains
i'm going to focus on the time between
six
in the morning until noon what we find
is almost 45 percent of the gram stains
we reported during that period of time
rather than the distribution you see in
this slide above
it gets more dramatic when you look at
identification
almost 80 percent of the organisms are
identified and reported between
eight o'clock and i'm sorry six o'clock
in the morning
and noon and for susceptibility tests
it's over 80 percent are reported during
that same time
frame what we see then is that the
results are not being reported
when they would be available but rather
the work is being performed it's
convenient of the laboratory
and i think what we have to start
thinking about
is that blood cultures are something
that should be prioritized
in order to maximize the value and
timeliness
of those results
i want to remind everyone that the
laboratory only produces
one product we generate information
and for that information then it becomes
very important
that we look at the foundation and the
information is founded on its clinical
relevance
its accuracy and the timeliness that
we're able to generate that
information and give that information to
the physicians
as we look at clinical relevance we have
to prioritize the tests that influence
patient management and again don't think
about what's the easiest thing for the
laboratory to do
but rather think about what's the most
important thing
we can do that's going to influence the
outcome of the patients that we're
serving
we also have to make the test results
relevant to the user
i find it sometimes very frustrating to
see reports
that describe all the different
techniques for how we were able to
identify an organism or
how we were able to perform
susceptibility tests
and really lose the data that we really
want to communicate the information
we want to communicate buried in those
reports
we want to make this as easy to
understand and
is relevant for the physicians that are
managing our patients
obviously we have to have accuracy we
want to be able to identify
and eliminate any sources of air that
we're
encountering and we want to be able to
match the technical skills with the test
requirements so in other words if you
have a highly skilled if you have a
highly technical demanding test
we want to have our most skilled
technologists performing those tests
or training people to be able to perform
those steps
we should not assume that everyone can
perform the testing
uh is as
in accurate as as each other
this becomes very important to match
skills with test requirements
and then time to results we want to
optimize the workflow to match
the clinical needs i use sepsis as an
example
because we want to minimize all of those
areas where there's opportunities for
delays
which then will delay the information
going to our physicians
we want to eliminate the technical or
the workflow bottlenecks that exist
we need to identify those and we want to
reduce the manual processes
the redundancies and the confirmatory
tests that we perform
and again i'm not going to go into the
details of all of this but i
challenge you to look at the workflows
in your laboratory
and say are you prioritizing the most
important work
are you performing manual tests that
could be much more effectively
and accurately automated are you doing
redundant tests because you don't have
confidence in the results
or do you have to perform confirmatory
tests because you don't get a definitive
answer
with your initial test all of those are
ways that we should challenge ourselves
to be able to get results in a much more
timely way
so again our point of emphasis has to be
information how good is this information
how accurate is the information
how tiny timely is the information
excuse me what i would like to do
is to spend the last few minutes of this
presentation
talking about some of the opportunities
we have
in order to use data to more effectively
manage
our laboratories i should step back and
make a comment
for of the last 10 years i've been
working at beck and dickinson but before
that for
more than 35 years i directed clinical
laboratories
one of my frustrations in directing
clinical laboratories was that it was
very difficult to be able to give data
that i could use in order to more
effectively manage my laboratory
to be able to see where i had problems
where i had gaps
where i had inefficiencies um
and to be able to quantitate it in a way
that i could show my
my hospital administrators the ones that
would pay my bills
exactly where there was opportunities to
improve the work that we were
doing we have those tools available now
and we have to be able to use those
in order to maximize the value of the
information that we're generating
and we have to look at each step of the
diagnostic pathway
we tend to focus on the analytical phase
because that's what we see in front of
it that's what's in the laboratory
but we have to think about the
pre-analytical phase the specimen
collection
and transport to the laboratory because
frankly we could do the most
accurate testing and most rapid testing
uh
in the world but if the specimen we're
working with
is compromised then our efforts in the
laboratory are wasted
in the same way we have to focus on how
is that data being communicated to the
physician
to maximize their ability to be able to
effectively manage their patients
and so when we think about when
we use sepsis again as an example when
we think about blood cultures and what
we do with blood cultures
we have to think about a number of
things i've mentioned some of these
already we think about the blood volume
that's being collected
you want to make sure we have enough
bottles to be able to manage
for our patients we want to reduce our
contamination rates we want to identify
what our contamination rates are
we want to know what our positivity rate
is
we want to know how many blood cultures
are we receiving from a patient
as an example whether we receive one
bottle or two bottles
two coaches three cultures or what and
what's the turnaround time
and of that turnaround time if we see
delays where are those delays occurring
so all of those are different types of
activities that
we now have tools to be able to measure
to allow us to be able to do
laboratory processing much more
efficiently
we also see networks of hospitals being
built
and this is clearly the trend in the
future in the european countries in the
asian countries
this is very very common in the united
states we're starting to see this
much more frequently in canada they've
seen this for a number of years
where you have a number of hospitals
that are linked together
and so what you want to be able to do is
to look at those
laboratories look at the hospitals and
their laboratories
and be able to say how do we compare
is one hospital doing a better job than
another
where do we see gaps and where do we see
needs and how can we
learn from one hospital their good
practices and apply them across our
network
and again we now have informatics that
allow us to
connect these hospitals together to
integrate the data to analyze the data
and then empower us to be able to make
improvements that are going to drive
important changes that not only impact
on the financial
aspects of the laboratory but much more
importantly on the clinical aspects
of the physicians and patients that
we're serving
so as we think about enterprise
analytics they provide
insights that can help enable continuous
improvement
in the practices of multiple laboratory
institutions
we can automate data aggregation and
normalization across
all of the connected sites we can have
on-demand access to insights at any time
anywhere in the system so if we suspect
we have a problem we can look at our
hospital
we look at the hospital next door we can
compare the performance of each
we can track the blood culture metrics
not just in our hospital
but across this network of laboratories
and we can compare that to see who's
doing a good job
who's maybe falling short and then
finally we can
compare laboratory performance against
the user-defined
benchmarks so we can establish a
benchmark for the network
we can then compare each individual
hospital to this
benchmark and make sure that we can
achieve
what we consider our target goals i'm
just going to give a couple of examples
of how this is in the upper left hand
corner
we see two circles the red circle in the
upper left hand corner
is the i'm having a hard time reading
this so i apologize
positive blood cultures are very low
percent one point three percent
next to that is the contamination rate
which is very good it's less than one
percent at zero point four percent
the to the right of that we see
laboratory 2 which has a higher percent
positivity 7.5 percent
and slightly higher contamination rate
but below that 2 percent that i
recommended
and then underneath we see the third
laboratory
which again has a high percent
positivity rate
but also what i would consider an
unacceptably high contamination rate
so this allows us to take the in the
in the box with the eight circles we
have the average for
all all three hospitals and then the
individual hospitals
and it allows us to then start comparing
the hospitals to see
where we can make some improvements you
look at blood contamination rate and
again
the top line we see first the first two
lines
for the enterprise the positivity rate
and the contamination rate
both of those are unacceptable we see
laboratory 1
which has again unacceptably low
positivity rate
and high contamination rate laboratory 2
is doing better with the positivity rate
but still has a high contamination rate
and so then you
implement changes and what you can see
then is
improvements and so the lower set of
six circles we see for the enterprise
they've
achieved their targets of a high
positivity rate a low contamination rate
laboratory one still has contamination
problems but it's improved its
positivity rate
and laboratory two has improved both
positivity and lowered contamination
rate
this allows you to start comparing among
the hospitals
in your network and this is just one
example
looking at positivity and contamination
rates
you can also monitor the amount of blood
that's being put into the bottles and
this is
in this graph that illustrates it over a
period of time a number of different
weeks
and what we have are four lines for four
different hospitals and then the
enterprise
itself and what you see is that the
blood volume varies
for each of the hospitals and this gives
you an opportunity
to say this is a hospital where we need
to make an
improvement and you can monitor that
improvement over time
so again shows you how you can use
analytics to improve your overall
performance
the same type of data for contamination
you can measure the contamination rates
over time and again identify hospitals
with a poor contamination rate
and measure how you know procedures like
what i
talked about having phlebotomist having
training having feedback
even using blood diversion can decrease
the contamination rate that you see in
your hospital
or in your network this
is a study that looks at workflow it's a
little bit difficult to see the bars but
you can measure
the amount of time from collection to
receipt in the laboratory
the amount of time from receipt until it
when the bottles are put into the blood
culture instrument
the amount of time it takes for the
bottles to turn positive in the
instrument
and then how much time from when the
bottles turned positive to when the
bottles were removed
for two different laboratories over a
different period of time
and what they're able to do is to
monitor that and determine
is there an area where we need the focus
let's say
the dark blue bars at the end is how
much time it takes to remove the bottles
from that are positive from the
incubator
maybe that's an opportunity how you can
reduce that
your the other problem could be from
when it's received in the laboratory to
when it's put
into the incubator and again you can
identify
where you see delays and how you can
start eliminating those delays and
improving your turnaround time
and again just using the same thing with
five different hospitals to be able to
compare the different hospitals
so i think what's what's really critical
as we think about this
we have to empower the multi-lab
institutions to impact on the blood
culture metrics
and drive operational and financial
outcome improvements
we you are given tools now where you can
do this and i think that's really
critically important
you can automate the way we collect the
data and normalize it you can access it
from a centralized dashboard and be able
to aggregate those reports in the
analytics
we have the ability to compare the
performance of different laboratories
for the key metrics
and we can use user defined by
benchmarking
to be able to define targets for each of
the hospitals and our network
and again this can be done for an
individual hospital or it can be done
for a network of hospitals but we
finally now
have tools that allow us to do this
so let me summarize what i've tried to
cover in this presentation
the microbiology laboratory is critical
for speci
for sepsis management best practices
including minimizing contamination and
maximizing positive blood cultures
are something that we can control and we
should control those
for optimum laboratory efficiency
we need to implement changes that will
provide timely clinical value
for physicians and their patients and
then finally
laboratory efficiency and clinical value
required data analytics
so that we can measure the success of
our efforts in the laboratory
and with that i want to thank you for
your attention i hope you found this
useful maybe
maybe more importantly i hope you found
it provocative
and make you start thinking about how
you and your laboratories
can do things differently to impact in
patient care
so that thank you very much for your
attention i think we have maybe some
time to
answer questions
yes dr murray thank you yes thank you
for your informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so we'll get started with our first
question here
dr murray the bd blood culture bottles
have some manufacturing variation
in the media fill and label placement
these factors impact the accuracy of the
blood fill volume for our collectors
has bd looked to improve the bottle
labels specifically the fill line gauge
so it's a very interesting question
the short answer is yes but
but maybe it's important to talk about
the complexity of the blood culture
bottles
if you think about the bottle it doesn't
just have medium in it
it has a sensor to detect rope
it has resins to inactivate antibiotics
and it has the culture medium that's in
the bottle
each of those can vary slightly in the
volume that's
administered into the that's placed into
the bottle
and i will tell you that's not just the
problem that we have this is a problem
that exists for
all of the commercial manufacturers of
blood culture bottles
so for the fill line to be able to
do this most accurately which you would
want to be able to do
is at the time the bottle is
manufactured
and at the time the bottles have been
filled to be able to look at that
and then to establish where you should
feel
in other words measure the volume of
the top of the profits there
and then say what is 10 mls more and be
able to mark that
on the labels so that it becomes obvious
what the fuel line should be
unless that's unless it's done that way
i can guarantee you the variation that
exists is going to make it very
difficult
to be able to fill the bottles um
properly
and and frankly there's better solutions
than using fill lines and i think maybe
the future will see that
other questions thank you dr murray so
our next question is
who are the key stakeholders you see
making an impact within a sepsis
management team
you know if you think about that the key
stakeholder
is the patient we have to do the best we
can for that patient
now the the bridge between the
laboratory
information that we generate and the
patient who's going to receive the
treatment is obviously the physician
but it's a physician team really so you
have the physician
who's going to make decisions about how
to manage the patient
we have people in the pharmacy that are
going to provide guidance for doing
susceptibility
for interpreting the susceptibility test
so when we talk about stakeholders
we have to really talk about the
physician
the people that help the physician make
decisions and the patient who receives
the
the results of those i think the other
stakeholder that we have to be realistic
to acknowledge is our hospital
administrators what they want us to do
is provide the most value for the
patients that we manage
at the most affordable cost and so as we
look at ways that we can
streamline the way we do blood cultures
the way we run our laboratories
how we can reduce the cost associated
with with that
we benefit that other stakeholder the
one that's paying the bills
and it looks like we have time for maybe
one maybe two more questions
does bd provide collection kits that
will help
standardize collection protocols
so i can i can answer yes they do
um and also we have a
and what may be obvious to everybody
maybe not um
bd diagnostic system that business
merged with our pre-analytical system or
pas
business and one of the strengths that
pas
brought to this partnership is a very
strong educational team
and so for the collection of blood
cultures properly
we have a very strong team that can help
you with that
uh for both instructions as well as
collection kits
one more question maybe yeah we could
squeeze one more in
all right uh let's go with this one
dr murray what are the consequences of
having an average volume
over 10 milliliters you know we um
a number of years ago we did some
studies
looking at actually reducing the size of
the blood culture bottles to
20 ml tube and mixing
half with broth in half with
with blood from a patient and we
actually saw
very very little impact uh in terms of
recovery on that now
we didn't extend those studies and so
we would have to really do a
comprehensive study of that to be able
to say what the impact
is i think it's far the far greater
damage
is caused by under filling the bottles
and overfilling the bottles
our algorithms and we have a large
number of algorithms that are used to
analyze the
bottles those those algorithms are based
on a proper fill
and so there is some problems with an
overfill but again
i would worry much more about
under-filled bottled bottles than
overfilled bottles
thank you again dr marie do you have any
final comments for our audience
well again i i would go back to what i
said in my conclusion
concluding comments i want to challenge
people that listen to these um
webinars i i've done these for many
years i've listened to them for many
years
um i've talked at national meetings and
i think all too often
we'll go and say that was really good
talk or yeah i understand that or i
learned something
but we don't necessarily do something
and what i want to challenge you to do
is to do something look at your lab look
at what you're doing
look at opportunities to make an
improvement doesn't necessarily mean you
buy a new technology it means you just
do things better
and i think every laboratory has an
opportunity to do things better
so that's that's how i would like to
conclude this is that challenge to you
to improve what you do to benefit the
patients you're taking care of
thank you
wonderful before we go i'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information that you provided at the
time of registration
we would like to once again thank dr
murray for his time today his important
research in this amazing presentation
we would also like to thank labberts and
our sponsor bd
for underwriting today's educational
webcast you can view the webinar on
demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now stay happy stay
healthy and safe
and until next time bye